okay so recently my media coach Jennie
moon love you Janey challenged me to
look back on my old videos and talk
about them I guess with you and and do a
quick review I haven't looked at my
stuff for a long time when I started
doing these videos I don't know how many
years ago I guess we'll find out I did
it because I I'm a visual learner I
learned from watching things as I wanted
to create content that people could
learn from as well and I sucked at the
beginning and so I've gotten better and
better and better and better and she
said it'd be fun for you to go back and
look at some where you really old stuff
and comment on it so today I'm going to
accept Jamie's challenge and see what
happens so i've loaded up my page i
don't even know how to go out and find
old videos let's see videos date newest
oldest or oldest to newest there we go
friends that was actually a surprisingly
great YouTube experience although i love
that how oldest to newest shows me one
month ago as my oldest video great so it
wasn't an awesome experience that's
terrible so how do I find my oldest
videos you'd think by going date oldest
to newest I find my oldest video the
first ones I were doing was about the
famous entrepreneur profiles what would
I call it Walt Disney documentary Disney
success story
there it is okay so is this i know
there's a story behind this one I didn't
feel comfortable doing videos myself so
I partnered up with fanta media I was
run by an entrepreneur friend of mine in
mark Draeger and he's a videographer
right that was his whole company so I
said okay mark I want to do this video
on Walt Disney I'm gonna put on my
website and give you some exposure can
your team come in and help me and this
is the result so let's let's play a
little bit so the first part is the a
fanta kind of promo his company's called
phantom media and then Owen welcome oh
my God look at that my name is Evan
Carmichael today I'm so nervous I hate
sitting down I hate sitting down and
talking because I don't get the vibe
like I got the stand-up desk I remember
he orchestrated it he came to my office
and he orchestrated it so that I'd be he
had the light behind me and sitting in a
desk and in this pose and I was felt so
awkward so he made this entry for me we
use this a couple times a partner with
marc a couple times everyone goes well
oh my god so i think i've got a tie on I
was so stressed out making this video
that I had to I was trying to memorize
everything I wasn't in the zone I was
trying to memorize the lines and so he
cut to a lot of pictures when I'm
thinking like this and trying to the
content is still great but there's no
passion look at me man this had nothing
to do with with mark mark ii did a great
job it was all me was all me sucking on
camera but this was my first video wow I
developed a passion for John I'm talking
about his passion and I have zero
passion I'm telling the story we made
this and we put it up and it had 40,000
views he broke 2019 April 2019 wow it's
almost five years because i didn't i
didn't know what to do after this I felt
like God it wasn't great I felt I felt
embarrassed looking at it because this
was actually this was actually
professionally produced I didn't make
this myself let's look at the Harlem
Harley
Davidson onto a month great because he
is doing with rapid Nepal wow it's
really bad doc I think this is when I
started recording at myself mark only
came in for the first video hello so
boring again series dedicated to helping
entrepreneurs find a shortcut the
business accepts listen to me I'm
modeling the strategies and ideas of
other thing I feel like I'm gonna fall
asleep using my Bible strategies
implemented your business this is at my
office see the content was great write
the content was great the delivery was
just started terrible terrible I'm glad
we put in these pictures I think I
started editing this I know I guess it
was still mark but still Marquez they
had to help find the pictures because I
was taking him too long to find the
pictures his team so I help find the
pictures and then we we put them up and
he mixed them if it was just me on
camera it would have it would have
failed royally man holy cat how old
would this do 7,000 views 53like c53
thumbs up one thumb down that's still
decent people it's still decent okay
what's the next one Hershey success
Hershey success Milton Hershey success
story five years ago
Oh fanta media Phantom media the intro
back oh this one was great okay so this
one let me pause this here this is great
so now I started using my flip camera so
i started using my flip camera
experiment in right this is little flip
camera and i put it on a shelf kind of
like this and put on the shelf facing me
but because i kept stopping starting
subway starting the camera kept moving
it wasn't quite stable when i started
talking so you watch this video you
watch this video it's always it's moving
and wiggling around but whatever i still
posted it on top of that this is this is
just done at home and there's two holes
in the wall behind me because i had
pictures up on the wall i thought i'll
take them off and i'll have a nice clean
background on a white background but
then you see these holes in the wall and
i looked at like man this is such a bad
video right like the camera shaking its
bad quality there's holes in the wall I
sound like I'm gonna fall asleep but
still thirteen thousand views 59 thumbs
up one thumbs down that's not that's not
that's not too shabby like this is this
is how we started and built it up
there's one more that's bad what's a PT
Barnum one PT Barnum was up the next one
and PT Barnum PT Barnum this one I
remember I am so this look at this one I
borrowed a buddy of Mines camera it's
like okay now I'm gonna step up I mean I
still didn't you know invest in anything
yet I'm buying a buddy of Mines camera
and I didn't know that you're not
supposed to speak with the light
directly behind you right so I'm so dark
because I'm feeling this at my old house
and the light is behind me and again
like so this time I have a tripod I've
got a half decent camera as a test I was
just borrowing stuff as a test and the
content again is ok but then like look
at the quality it's so bad it's brutal
what I did here was I i modified it so i
will only be talking on camera for a
short amount of time so i only had to
remember a few things and then when you
get into his story his service is easy
i'm reading it what we're showing
pictures so again i had to find all
these pictures to give to mark so we
could put something up
barnum sir good quality again but no
just no passion moving to the city with
Gus do with Gustav read sleepy sweep
through the city with gusto you hear
that it's brutal oh man this one sixteen
thousand views a hundred and one thumbs
up two thumbs downs and he was still
decent man good content but just
experimenting right experian with other
people's gear it's embarrassing hate
looking at this stuff all of my videos
at the start were famous entrepreneur
profiles and then I don't member when I
started answering questions and do
another stuff let's see what they find a
three years ago business ideas
productivity in the workplace in the
workplace workplace 400 for
entrepreneurs three keywords there this
one okay so why so for for basically two
years I did just a famous entrepreneur
stories and I would find kind of three
lessons to share and then this is the
first one that I did that was was not
related to a famous entrepreneur I don't
think special video edition ah so ask
Evan started I don't know I think it
started in the newsletter and so now I
this is the first video I'm doing this
at my home i'm using my my nikon DSLR
camera and i remember i had to have my
sister my wife come in and and focus it
on me because it is an auto focus and
then leave the room because I was too
nervous to do it in front of them and
every time i did a video they'd have to
do that same process over and over again
look one of the most common questions
that I get
entrepreneur's how can it be more
productive so we're going to look at how
you can eliminate automate and delegate
you with I still talk about a lemony
autumn a delegate is just I think it's
like Jurassic Park sound trackers help
the other back no it's gladiator it's a
gladiator like the peaceful song in the
background I think now I don't mark got
tired of me or what was happening I I
started editing these videos and this
was just um what's the windows tool
movie maker this is movie maker so I'm
just finding my pictures I put in the
gladiator theme song in the background
throwing some pictures up and again i'm
reading this so that's why i had to have
pictures because i'm reading this as
we're going just I was barely on camera
because I couldn't remember enough and I
was so happy with what I was doing you
know like I memorized these four
sentences that I had to say on camera
man it's all pictures all the way
through here it's all just pictures and
then I just came back at the end I think
yeah Wow see I was too scared to come on
camera so just did the intro extra but
the contents the same can let's go where
am I thank you for joining me for this
special video edition I'd also love to
hear your thoughts and comments if you
want
comment below and taking the neck that
is that Wow was my extra more info at
the website cute the gladiator music how
long was that extra just sitting on my
website listen to the gladiator music oh
my god hilarious okay what else did I do
oh I did a book about my favorite sales
and marketing book let's look at that
because i just recently did a book about
the top seven books i think of seven
that entrepreneurs need to read but i
talked about one of the books three
years ago let's see marketing book ask
heaven three years ago only 270 views ah
so sad oh ok so now I hired somebody on
odesk we're fast forward a little bit my
first video editor because because was
taking too much my time to edit this
stuff and I landed a deal with with
telus which was a telecom company here
in Canada where I had budget now to go
to make some of these famous
entrepreneur video so write a blog post
for them get some video added to it and
so like okay well now I'm getting I'm
getting paid a little bit so I can
afford to go and hire somebody to help
me because of the part I hated the most
was doing editing I wasn't very good at
it so I hired somebody on odesk and he
made this intro for me too and for a lot
of my videos that's my standard intro
to another video edition of ask Evan in
this video I want to answer questions
for one of our readers Hubert who asked
me what my favorite sales and marketing
book is so are going to have books are
it a lot of blogs and with a lot of
articles the format is not that
different than what i do now right it's
almost the same stuff I remember this is
in my basement now at the house and I've
got these lights set up on me I did so
much experimentation with how do you get
the lights you know do I wear a light
color I found that later I should be
wearing a dark color shirt instead of a
light color because that makes my face
lighting up a little bit more Fred
factor still here oh no it's in my room
I'm reading it again I'm reading again
right now Fred factor John Sanborn ug
it's on my shelf thank you lean back as
well it seems today so it's all just
like one angle there's no zoom in zoom
out snow fun stuff happening the videos
but basically I wanted to do this as a
way to connect with my audience they
were asking me questions and instead of
me you know writing an email to them all
the time I made a video response ok what
else do we have so I just recorded a
David Ogilvy famous Friday Christina's
pop baki pointed the wrong way let's pop
that up and I did 13 years ago as well
so let's see how that David Ogilvy
jocular so sorry there we go there it is
for what years this is this Assad who
was my first video editor side then got
kidnapped and held for ransom and
disappeared for months oh so this is
where yeah that was intense this is this
is at my office again I rotate it like I
was figuring out I sucked at this I mean
this is using my my nikon DSLR at the
office nobody could be at the office an
experiment in different rooms and
different lighting and tried to get the
best looking i'm wearing this colored
shirt with a man I used to be so dressed
up this is me editing this is my editing
I could tell and there's a title this is
still all done with them movie maker
yeah movie maker but here's two years
two years oh I did the whiteboard phase
yeah where's the insurance okay how to
sell insurance so this was great so I
got experiment right you got to keep
experimenting find your voice find out
what works for you I'm trying to stuff
all the time that doesn't work until you
find you know what does work so this is
one I thought he had a whiteboard in my
office why don't I write stuff down on
the whiteboard as a way to answer
people's question I think it did maybe
five or six or maybe ten of these kinds
of videos and what i would do is let's
see is it shows that i had a hard time
getting the lighting to work well this
actually looks pretty good I thought it
was way worse than then it turned out I
would write the answer so what I was
going to say just below so I would have
to go in the whiteboard and draw this
black line under where the camera
stopped filling so just around where my
shirt is here and then would write down
what I was going to say so I would
remember because I didn't I didn't
remember so just right Joe insurance at
the top and then start writing so let's
see
how's my handwriting out of Wow what
does that even say customers I guys
let's Prudhoe at the end of the day this
just took too much time to do to think
of what I was going to say and then
write it and I thought that lighting was
bad i found there's a lot of glare
coming off the white boar and I didn't
know how to solve it but this isn't
actually that that it's not that bad
maybe we should do some more white board
but i got like gotta work on my
handwriting I don't write dianna do
people write anymore I don't know I
don't write I'm still boring they'll
listen to me video especially if you
haven't met them yet it's um if you'll
connect their media not this one did
well though 64,000 views 737 thumbs up
this is still getting a lot of views and
people look at it and they say like
let's look at a recent comment they're
still getting comments see what the most
recent winners thanks for the info take
your advice like it's still getting it's
still getting some views I spent a lot
of time on this video the info was
pretty good but again my delivery was
just terrible I got the collared shirt
so I lost my sweater though the sweater
is gone and now i'm just wearing the
collared shirts and I got the dark
collared shirt because I knew that on
the white background it pops a little
bit more so I'm getting I'm getting
better I'm slowly learning my way
through this oh I think I have a
microphone to do have a microphone on if
somebody I think its just oh you know
why I remember this I didn't want that I
got a clip Mike I got it on here I
didn't want it to be seen i thought like
put Mike you shouldn't let that be in
the camera so we wear a button shirt and
then around here I figure out where the
cut off of my shirt was and just put the
but that the mic a little bit lower so a
capture my audio I don't know mike is
fine that I'm not worried about it so I
use a clip Mike because in my old videos
i was just using the camera mic and it
was echoey and people were complaining
about the audio I got a lot of
complaints so I decided hey I'm starting
to make some money from these videos so
now I'm going to invest in my gear a
little bit more this camera too i
upgraded to a sony handycam which i
don't have anymore oh do I have it I
think I'd she still have it yeah dude my
old camera sony handycam I kept
upgrading that costco and I got this one
because it had an external mic jack a
lot of the cheaper cameras they don't
have an external mic jack relisted
didn't when I was getting started
and i got it from costco because you can
return it within 30 days where the
camera stores is only seven days so it's
not enough time to test it out so i got
this which had the external mic jack and
then i bought this clip is still at
stain pool turns out there's still the
same clip Mike that I used since i got
this it's a couple years old but it
still works I did webinars hearth so
this is newer this is two years old is
august i guess is more in two years old
says two years old but that's it's more
in two years old no I guess it's two
years old two and a half years old this
is still with sad my first guy i changed
my tagline to we help entrepreneurs over
40 million entrepreneurs helped and
counting I started doing webinars as a
test again this is one thing that I
wanted to test out I made these
PowerPoint files and then I I got online
I don't know if his once a month or
whatever it was and started making these
videos and they got some not really our
comment but some decent views and I
don't know why I stopped I guess it
wasn't getting enough wasn't getting
enough traction or maybe I think was a
lot of work to make these slides was a
crap ton of work and it wasn't getting
huge pick up on it like three comments
on them and only one of them wasn't me
right so uncommon all that work for one
coming ah so I stopped I did I did five
out of ten and then we never finished
then you know what nobody cared so I
stopped doing it anyway right if you
stop doing something that people write
and say where'd it go they make you pay
attention what else do we have what
inspires you ask Kevin ok so then then
why only 61 views holy cow it's like
it's getting worse oh I'm going to do
this one this one this one I have my
phone so then I started doing out of my
house and instead of just doing in the
basement I started doing it upstairs
with a with with stuff in the background
I start experience up in the background
they want a simple white wall so this is
me this is my old house I would just get
my phone out have the questions and read
the question and answer it I had to make
sure that everything was clean right
there's a lot of house in the background
there so I had to make sure everything
was spotless I can get going I had to
have a huge extra large french vanilla
cappuccino sitting there waiting for me
so I could drink it back in between
questions or a great question that a lot
of home base and look how much energy i
have go through sort of isn't one of the
hardest things that you ever gonna do so
bad i have no energy acht up on fri
traelo I've got zero energy here I
thought this was pretty good I thought I
was getting better Wow and then one
hustle while you wait Oh still I'm still
doing I still can't do a full video
myself this is how old februari 2013 so
this is this is almost two years ago i'm
still not doing a full video myself i
still have to do the intro and then have
a script that I type and read and show
pictures on top of it man it took me a
long time to build this up oh jeez
what's next this starts getting better
so april 2013 so this is when i started
working with my agent and he challenged
me to make a raw video just be on camera
all the time and be passionate energetic
emotional tell me your story tell me
something inspirational and the raw
series was it was just basically
standing in front of the camera and not
edited not polished that's why it was
raw and i did so many he made me do so
many versions most of these aren't live
that you can see i published a few of
them so this 1 130 want two views 9
thumbs ups let's see how I'm doing you
can't come in the town it's going to be
tough this is gonna be one of the
hardest things you've ever done in your
life you're going to doubt yourself
you're going to win the why you don't go
back and get a job it's starting to get
there you can start the energy is
starting to flow even if you mana
success either view the smartest person
in the world office of great one there's
a great one where I'm sitting this is a
memorable moment we got to find this
video there's one I'm ranting it's a
Ross series EP raw let's see raw see if
I can find it turning points starting to
come working with my agent here rah get
rid of my books yes fighting with
entrepreneurs who don't think big yes
okay so this one got me this one got me
upset I was I was
I came back from a meeting i think was
my mastermind group and and I was just
pissed off that they were thinking so
small and I just I was listening to the
advice from an agent to say just when
you're excited about something when
you're emotional film it right away
don't wait until next week to go on film
it just sit down and film on so I'm
sitting here in my room sitting on the
floor with my laptop camera so the
quality is not great it's night so
there's not a lot of natural light I was
I felt like this was a turning point
video for me but let's see how good is
one year ago so when is this this is
September 26 2013 oh I mom to my new
logo so we're moving to Christina now
Christina is in the house Christina say
hi hi so she made a new logo for me we
started working with the sound effects
as I was flying in and gotten better
over the videos but we got oh that's the
one with the tree i 7 i'm really
frustrated tonight i got into fights
with five different entrepreneurs today
challenging day i had tons of meetings
lined up pain these are entrepreneurs
who came to me and they have problems
with their business and they're not
getting the results that they want out
of their company and they're holding
themselves back and I'd give them great
advice I hated to the most of a clarity
so obvious this is what you need to do
to make a bigger impact to grow a bigger
company and they're so resistant to
change they're so locked into their
current mindset so I'm going to do
anything slightly out of the ordinary
thus I I know what else I got some raw
raw stuff now 123 views 15 thumbs ups
did I get any likes I did it shut up for
likes 12 comments hey we're getting
better getting some comments you can
leave me the water but you can't make me
drink love your passions so it's the
first like ma getting some passion still
not what I'm doing now but it's closed
it's closed this is good turning point
conversation here then what do we have
after that how to minimize the chance of
failing so this is Christina now I was a
little bit older because I hope
learn about a business learn about an
industry so so that's a great point
deposit on it this is Christina's work
and Christina played around with the
lighting effects it is not my office so
it's this was a lot more yellow she
played around with a lot and she started
panning and zooming and I had to go get
a new camera because of Christina's
editing work as she would punch in on me
bunch and the quality of the camera
degraded because when you zoom you lose
the quality so i had to get a better
camera that would allow for still HD
video when you zoom them what else i
have a hickey on my neck there some
people are asking is that a hickey yeah
well you know whatever I'll just goes to
go with it I covered it up a little bit
but not enough you can see the
microphone on there you see go get some
experience by working for somebody who
you respect in the business and they'll
teach you the ropes and minimize your
chances of failing when you start your
own business so this is important
because a lot of people make videos like
oh you know I have a pimple a little my
head that you can see I've got this
hickey on my neck still do your video
right you're going to find excuses every
day for not doing your video get up
there and do it this video how well did
it do 98 views hungry entrepreneurs
deserve help 98 98 years 8 thumbs up one
thumbs down any comments thanks all he
sits all the advice so like I wasn't
getting huge traction yet but this is
what happens right like that one comment
from Chris ah I got a comment solid
advice yes it fuels me to keep going
give me something one little ounce for
those of you guys watching other
people's videos if there's no comments
leave a comment because that one piece
that that's like somebody's paying
attention right be that change for
somebody Chris probably made my day here
when he said solid advice some passion
is something I really believe in you
have to start a business around
something that you're passionate out
that gives you the greatest chance of
success me more so I'm still kind of
boring but I'm getting better getting
better this is starting to happen one so
the fact that you look
what else was the next one for the
people for people in your network this
is Evan Carmichael so listen it's really
important that you support the people in
your network okay people have so this
came as part of my training with my
agent to to do raw videos to be in the
moment to do something spontaneous so I
decided to call up this guy who is also
at the agency who introduced me to the
agency Shawn Moffitt and just randomly
calling up on myself with these are the
days when I use my cell phone oh so
sweet the Shawn Moffitt Sean hasn't come
back to how are you listen man before we
get too far I've got you on speaker and
i'm doing a video yeah you're on my
video talking about a solution to be a
training and i thank you that email did
you get it ok ok I mysticism doing the
videos now so this was a test where I
started recording conversations I
remember I had one call I was I was
filming and my agent calls me and I nee
act we had we were working on something
we had exciting news but I didn't tell
him I was recording it I recorded the
whole call and then he said he didn't
want to use a that's some quality
footage right Steve man that was some
quality footage you could have used I'm
still hurting a little bit not be able
to use that I didn't do this again maybe
I should do this what if you guys think
I should call people up spontaneously
and talk to them on a live video leave a
comment let me know okay what was next
zipcar Evan Carmichael so this was
another test as a year ago so I like
again working with my agency i
experiment with a whole bunch of stuff
and this was my first zipcar experience
400 members okay let's try it up put it
the keys in it doesn't stop it starts I
hope I have more in the quarter tank of
gas that was awesome Wow all right so I
did a whole bunch of videos just
experimenting doing live stuff at
finding my flow finding what works for
me seeing what kind of new videos I
wanted to do how to make professional
videos Evan Carmichael so now this a
year ago I'm making videos on how to
make professional videos pretty good
this is the new logo do you create
refreshes my old videos it's a question
i got from one of my readers Karen great
question kind of a long story but
basically wrote I'm still reading off my
phone this professionalism you don't do
that anymore loosing my videos if I can
give her some advice so Karen request so
this is at the office this is we've seen
you see the punch punch in a nap
Christina added some magic hate spending
money until I'm making I'm telling my
story using the clip Mike still got that
I still have the branding yet i don't
have the shirt and something into the ec
gear happening yet cuz to do it in
public so this was a challenge that my
agent gave me to go out and speak in
public cuz i was afraid of it where I
was you know everything was in the
confines of my housework or my my office
and and I got you know I got more
comfortable with it my sister could be
in the room my staff could be in the
room but he wanted me to do something
out in public with my phone and I was
freaking out so i decided i do a video
about doing speaking in public and again
this is more for me only 200 use 13
thumbs ups probably a few comments some
some decent comments
they're gone wrong but do your thing
public don't do it in public me that
whatever do your thing in public doesn't
sound that much better either this is
you should be trying to have an impact
you can have a message but the passions
coming out the passions coming out
anyway we're starting to get some more
comments I think right on still not that
much man five comments two or three of
them our minds moving in to comments on
these videos but this is the hustle
right like those two comments ah
somebody says evidence video is awesome
yes right drives gonna keep going this
is how when did I start this I started
five years ago this is this is one year
ago one year ago i'm only getting two
comments on the video man a lot is
exploded anyway but you keep like keep
hustlin I'm still pumping out the videos
still getting better this is the work
you got to put in when you see very
minimal results at the start what's the
first video where I have a shirt on
tough times Evan Carmichael so this is
one of the first videos where I'm
wearing a branded shirt through hard
times a buddy mine is going through a
hard time in his life this is a great
video i sent him this is this is the
most like emotional video that I did
where I'm talking about a really hard
year that i had about being stressed out
and gaining weight and going through a
divorce and all of this bad stuff to
happen to me in my life and it happened
because i was talking to a buddy of mine
he was going through it and I realized
that what I wrote in that message i I've
never really shared with people before
and I haven't shared it with you and I
thought that the message might help you
if you're going through a hard time in
your life right now and it's sharing my
story so that so this was a good start I
but it was I wanted to show this because
the first video that I had to bring the
shirt on and I remember there was a
company called Rapa Nui that had this
shirt that was I don't know how he found
the emailed me and said hey if you give
me that shirt i will aware on on you
know a week's worth of my videos and it
was also pretty emotional video so we
had 1,300 views 36 comments that's
what's up
is actually some of them are still
coming this is one week ago so you know
this is a really emotional store you
guys can check it out if you want but
but now we're starting to get a little
bit of traction we're like I'm pouring
my heart out here I'm starting to get
some comments and starting to get some
good views on the videos but it took me
it took me a year that's 2014 that's
only a year ago it took me it took him
four years to get to that point and it's
crazy man that's crazy step into fear
every time I go ten months ago I started
my first videos with my own shirts to
fear there are things that you need to
do in your business and in your life to
keep your goals that you are afraid of
if you want to bust down to your average
fashions coming out man the passions
coming out I was nervous I was scared I
was sweating my heart was pounding the
first time I got up on stage did you
must get you know presses starting to
calm our friends the whole week before
that house so we've gone through an
evolution man this is fun this is cool I
mean it's cancelled you know I was too
embarrassed to watch my old videos it's
actually not that bad watching it now
but I was too embarrassed watching home
videos and it was a point around the 800
video walk mark that I could watch my
own videos and not be embarrassed but
then there was this video that blew my
mind because I I inspired myself I like
watch like yeah I got to go do something
today that was only three months ago but
look at this video seventy-five thousand
views eighty thousand views 90
absolutely 36 comments if you're not
sure what to do next in your life if you
don't know what the study if you don't
know where to take your business the
best advice that I can give you right
now is to follow your flow find the
things that excite you that interesting
finding things that make you [ __ ] a lot
and go do that and since then now you
guys are feeling with the channel adding
videos answering the question still
doing a lot of experimentation this has
been a fun experience actually Jamie
thank you for the for the suggestion
it's been cool to watch the progress so
I started just as a way to give back to
help entrepreneurs I had to practice
everything I was memorizing script I was
barely on camera because i was reading
and showing pictures i was using shaky
cameras knew nothing about lighting was
dressing all business and professional
had
no comments on my videos but just kept
doing it and slowly they got better I
stopped edited in myself edited my
intros I got better gear I got better
with my agent and Janie's training to
speak more from the heart with more
passion even the same content but with
more passion and excitement and it's fun
to see the turning point so what the
turning points videos that the the first
one was to mark [ __ ] one the Walt
Disney one where I was super nervous and
sitting down trying to memorize the most
emotional turning point for me I think
was that raw one where I'm complaining
about not thinking big enough and then I
started getting more emotion into all of
my videos definitely I think Christina
to the team has been an awesome win and
then this follow your flow one that that
you know started exciting me started
getting me motivated myself watched my
own videos but you see the journey you
see my other videos had no comments very
few views and I kept going because one
or two comments on a video that was
enough to give me the excitement to want
to keep going trip down memory lane
Thank You Jani for the great suggestion
thank you guys for watching let me know
what you think about this video leave a
comment below subscribe to the channel
if you want to see more just like it
thank you so much I'll see you guys soon
props to Jason fonseka here for finding
the videos on his laptop and queuing
them up because you two broke on me so
there we go nice job son who even your
new leader isn't told me not to quit and
look for to them every week they have
changed my life thank you
you